україна азог проводити акції пит
мінюстом
адже вимагаючи строго не суди
корупціонера
[музика]
розум з демонстрантами та 24 особисто
льодопад ціль а я до зізналася дуа за
Ванич зручно та подумайте такі акції
радикальні app is їм набрати і сізо
політичному і ту
ліда родом з донецька якщо качан провини
бонатті кладуть його дівчину ховалиг
патріот cu doua золи та щеплення молодіжний
tabbert я бердянською захід
початки вірних вин із міністерства
разовим садом з кружляють я за новим
проти вже почала
нині ліда пройти у молодіжного
департаменті азову ризиковий підрозділ
books заснований на вас не 14 уроку пити
година провини на донбасі
сході регулярно українська армія дуги
малий ще могла зруби ти проти
сепаратистів
активіста бідного ласі воду грубо шукай
батальйони
азов бу водним знак полк став відомим
завди до того ж ви двоє вафа
проросійських бойовиків маріуполь методі
хлопців за покликання знати їх засланців бетил
з правою та дилогію з
адже слово колега чи daddy знала ще
азов сьогодні раз пачино та вимоги але
гарантію
[музика]
тут на полігоні біля Києва
але в окулярах будуть муштру вати азов нині
готівки близько pictor і тисячі бескова
служба active
полк наразі визнала до національної
гвардії піт порядку взагалі
міністерству внутрішніх справ у
центральному штабі азову сюди можна
потрапити і в загальних ок то чорне сонце
символ річки таке шоу кар засновував і
чи нацисти дати шкоду і запрячу і вона
поважаєш ці символи
мати подальшу історію розвідки в
сорокових уроках ви на взяв і сам і csl
на запалитися трапляється у когось просто
плачу за зачатою
а до заходу чим схожі навантаження wang з
істеричним і символом і
адже або друга покликання на інший тип
харчування pro ultra праві приводи
його організації для лівацької на ліву
ліберальну публіка на заході зазвучати
дістати не вигляд 100 і смердить і хоч
занадто скромних консервативних
цінностей для того, щоб стати і нацистам
обіцяних цінностей для того, щоб і в
принципі чесно кажу ніж вони абсолютно
наплювати і на t і скасування називають ворога
врагом і для білецького і всипали тисяч
на крем'янисті україни особ створу в
партію я до формального вигляду крому на вигляд
полку праві партії наволочки групи йдуть
чи здобудемо верховною радою
ще продуманий суворо ти влади своє буринь
а лідера поклику тут безперечно на номер
один азов хочу біднота юсі право сили в
україні
назвеш, але ж радикальності депутатам
у парламенті білоцький на прикуто
занурю переворотом мас вискочити з
милий влади
power ти з і ларису частини саморозпуску
ти сувар формула роду повірте митися з
робом
мазі бралася а для того щоб почати
боротьбу за плату
політолог андреасу ummon багата на рокки
у живому києві вин давно через
покійним поспішає за правим рукам у
україни нині перрі канони через грозу
перевороту правому батальйоном та німа
і буду раз вони цим не менше деки з них
організації зберегли свої права на зайве право
екстремістську символіку та можна його
також
ідеологію і сама з і ясна
проблематичним флопом красивим на часті
зміни ти
[музика]
вона поки що лихо любиш і українці приїду і
титу воєнізованого правого руку
види організуй вазу велить не tabbert для
дітей the pitt витків там ширші ці
націоналістичні або стикові гасять
правового українського націоналіста цей
про україну пологів спробую попрад
побратимства
223 км від характеру українця за
крим ауру бриз і здоровий спосіб жити
дисципліна та ненависть здоров'ю ціна в
чайний циля полку азів
молодих же нігтя таке ж право відблиски
людині
повіки люблять спорт та хочеш bourget через
свій україн акривних 2 поклик
викручується у своїх радикальних
політичних цілях